>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Jason Steinhauer: My
name is Jason Steinhauer.
I'm a program specialist
at the John W. Kluge Center
at the Library of Congress.
Today's program is presented
by the John W. Kluge Center
at the Library of Congress.
The Kluge Center is a vibrant
scholar center on Capital Hill
that brings together scholars and
researchers from around the world
to stimulate an energize one
another, to distill wisdom
from the library's rich
resources and to interact
with policy makers and the public.
The center offers opportunities
for senior scholars
and post-doctoral fellows as well as
Ph. D candidates to conduct research
in the Library of Congress
collections.
We also offer free public
lectures, conferences, symposia
and other programs such as this one.
And we administer the Kluge Prize
which recognizes lifetime
achievement in the study
of humanity, which
was recently awarded
to philosophers Jurgen
Habermas and Charles Taylor.
For more information
about the Kluge Center,
please visit our website,
LOC.gov/kluge.
I invite you to sign up
for our email list which is
on the table on the way out.
Today's program is titled Migration,
Asylum and the Role of the State:
Defining Boundaries,
Redefining Borders.
The event is part of a new program
series that we inaugurated last year
which we've titled
Kluge Conversations.
It's one of the wonderful
aspects of the Kluge Center
that we have a diversity of scholars
from around the world
under one roof.
And there are some wonderful
synergies that emerge.
And when scholars from different
disciplines are researching diverse
topics and begin to
speak to one another,
it is remarkable how many
commonalities can emerge.
In this instance we have a
Latin American historian,
an African historian and a
scholar from American studies.
Whose work it turns out
all investigate issues
of migrations, borders
and the state.
Hence the title.
This is also a topic that is much
in the news today, as we know,
both in the US and abroad.
And so the focus of our conversation
and the genesis for this event.
A word about how the
program will run.
We've asked each of our three
scholars to offer a brief overview
of their work at the Kluge Center
and their research project.
The scholars will then
engage in a conversation
that will take approximately
20-30 minutes.
After which we will
open up to you for Q&A.
And the scholars are eager to
engage you in this conversation.
So we'll leave plenty of time
for questions and we'll conclude
at approximately 5:00 PM.
We are also testing out for the
first time our new sound systems.
So hopefully everyone can hear us.
And if there are any problems
with the sound system during
the event, please let us know.
We will try to correct them.
And we'll also be eager to hear
your feedback on the systems
so that we can use
it for future events.
Finally, before we begin, brief
bios about each of the scholars.
Longer biographies
are on the handouts
which are available actually at
the front table when you come in.
But for the sake of future viewers
of this webcast I'll
also state the bios now.
Julia Young is an assistant
professor of history
at the Catholic University of
America here in Washington.
Her research and teaching
interests include Mexican
and Latin American history, the
history of Mexican migrations
to the United States, global
migrations, origin and diaspora.
She recently published her first
book, Mexican Exodus: Migration,
Religion and the Long Legacy
of Mexico's Cristero War,
which was written and
researched at the Kluge center.
The book examines Mexican migrants
who supported the Catholic church
during Mexico's Cristero War
in the late 1920's.
She has published articles
on the topic in the Americas
and the Catholic Historical Review.
She received her Ph. D in 2009
from the University of Chicago.
She is currently a Kluge
fellow through the center.
Ivan Chaar-Lopez is a Ph. D
candidate in the department
of American culture at the
University of Michigan.
His work traverses the boundaries
of digital studies, Latino studies,
history of technology
and US history.
He is currently a Kluge
fellow in digital studies
at the John W. Kluge center.
A relatively new fellowship
which we just launched in 2013.
He is the third holder
of that fellowship.
Katherine Luongo, we call her Kate.
Kate Luongo earned her Ph. D
at the University of Michigan
and is an associate professor of
history at Northeastern University.
She studies legal systems in
colonial and contemporary Africa,
particularly the intersections
of the supernatural and law.
Her work also examines
belonging in Africa
and in the global arena of asylum.
Her historical ethnography of
Kamba witchcraft was a finalist
for the African Studies
Association's Bethwell Ogot Prize.
And for the American Historical
Association Martin A. Klein award.
She is the coauthor of Obama
in Kenya: Contested Histories
of Politics and Belonging.
Which will be published by Ohio
University press in spring of 2016.
This book is the first scholarly
work to examine the history of Kenya
through the experiences
of the Obama family.
She is currently a Kluge Fellow
at the John W. Kluge Center,
completing her second monograph,
Witches and Bureaucrats:
African Witchcraft
and its Intersection
with Global Asylum Seeking.
So we will begin without
further ado.
We'll go in chronological order
from most distant to most recent.
And we'll begin with Julia.
>> Julia Young: Thank you.
Thank you, Jason, and thank you
to the Kluge Center and thank you
to all of you for being here.
IT's lovely to participate
in this conversation.
From 1920-1930 the population
of Mexico was on the move.
Hundreds of thousands of
Mexicans took to the railroads
and the highways to migrate
across the northern border
to the United States.
This migratory flow was so
enormous that the Mexican population
in the United States -- the
Mexican origin population --
doubled from about 500,000 to
about a little over 1 million.
There were several causes for this.
One of them was the 1910-1920
Mexican Revolution which sort
of decimated the countryside
and forced a lot
of people off their lands in
search of jobs and safety.
There was also population growth,
especially in the most
populated central part of Mexico.
There was a decline in
agricultural production.
Some environmental causes.
There were low wages in Mexico.
There were new transportation
networks, highways and railroads
that offered quicker
and easier ways to get
from Mexico to the United States.
And then in the United States
there were higher wages
and there were numerous
new jobs available
to Mexican migrants in particular.
Especially in agriculture.
So the cotton fields
and the sugar beet farms
of the Southwest and Midwest.
And in industry.
Steel factories, meatpacking plants.
And this was particularly
true in cities in the Midwest
and also in the US Southwest.
There was another cause though of
Mexican migration during the 1920's
and this one is a little
bit lesser known.
And this is the topic
that I work on.
It's a war now called
the Cristero War.
This was a very violent,
blood conflict
between Mexican Catholic partisans
and the Mexican government,
which was at the time, as a
result of the Mexican Revolution,
enacting very strict
anti-clerical legislations.
Legislation that forbade people
from essentially practicing
their Catholic faith in public.
It sound strange because
as you probably know,
Mexico is a vast majority
Catholic country.
But it's also a country where the
church and state had struggled
for really centuries
up until this time.
So this was an outbreak
of church state violence.
During the war, these catholic
partisans became militant
and they went to battle
against the federal government.
You know, armed with rifles but
also with crosses and scapulars
and religious medallions.
And they launched themselves
into battle with the battle cry
of viva Cristo ray, or
"Long live Christ the king."
And that's why they're
known as Cristeros,
or I guess it would be
Christers in English,
which doesn't sound very good.
They believed that they
were in a holy war and that
when they died they would become
martyrs, Catholic martyrs.
And so my book, which actually
somehow you got an old title
for my book, so I'll give you
the new title, the real title.
>> Jason Steinhauer: I'm sorry.
>> Julia Young: No, no, no.
It's floating out there somewhere.
It's called Mexican
Exodus: Emigrants,
Exiles and Refugees
of the Cristero War.
A little bit simpler.
So my book examines the ways that
this Mexican migration overlapped
with this religions
conflict that was going on.
And I find that the war actually
had a really significant impact
on this migrant community.
Partly it was just
coincidence, the geographic
and chronological coincidence.
The war happened at the same time
that this migration was happening.
And it happened in the
same place that most
of the migrants were
leaving: west/central Mexico.
The states -- for those
of you who know Mexico,
if you drew a big circle
around the city of Guadalajara,
that would be the region.
So it also impacted migration
in some more specific ways.
It created a refugee flow.
During the war, the Catholic
clergy, so priests, nuns, bishops,
were often actively persecuted
by the Mexican government.
And so they either
were forced into exile
or sought refuge in
the United States.
So there were about 2,000
members of the Catholic clergy
that migrated to the United States.
There was also a flow of political
exiles, Catholic activists who felt
that they had to leave the country
because they were in danger.
And these groups joined the
existing flow of economic emigrants
that were leaving the area already.
That left the area before the
war started and after it went on.
And it's this last group,
the sort of economic --
what we think of as
economic migrants --
that I think is of interest
for this particular discussion.
I'll bring up two cases in
particular very quickly.
One is a man named Miguel Vanegas.
I think these cases are sort of
indicative of the larger group
of people I'm talking about.
So Miguel Vanegas was the owner
of a general store in
the state of Jalisco.
Its capital city is
Guadalajara, Cristero hotbed.
He and his family were
strong Cristero supporters.
His brother joined the
Cristero troops and eventually,
ultimately died in the conflict,
was considered a martyr
within the family.
And he himself was also
a Cristero supporter.
When federal troops came to his
town, they were aware of his
and his family's sympathies.
And they let it be known that
he better leave the state
or he would potentially be killed.
So he went into hiding and
ultimately he went to Los Angeles
where he started a
grocery store very similar
to his general store
back home in Jalisco.
In Los Angeles, I think by the time
he left Mexico he had four children
and ultimately he and his
wife would have 10 children.
He raised all of these 10
children in Los Angeles.
The grocery store supported
the family.
And they stayed in the United
States after the war ended.
In fact, the descendants of
Miguel Vanegas still live
in Los Angeles to this day.
But he raised his children
to be good, devoted Catholics
and to remember and support this
Cristero cause back home in Mexico.
He and his family participated
in anti-government Catholic
activism from Los Angeles.
And they continued to view
themselves as Cristero supporters,
both during the 1920's
and afterwards.
Another quick case is the case of
Saradino Lopez, also from the state
of -- actually from
the state of Michoacan
but lived in the state of Jalisco.
He was a journalist who
wrote critical articles
about the Mexican government while
the Cristero war was going on.
He also was told that
he better leave
or he would find himself in danger.
And so he had friends who
were living outside of Chicago
in the growing Mexican
community outside Chicago.
And they told him,
"Well, come on over here.
There are jobs and you
can make a new home here."
So he came to Chicago,
he made it his home.
And he started a newspaper just
like the one he had run in Mexico.
And that newspaper was critical
of the Mexican government
and it actually was a tool
that rallied Cristero
support in the United States.
Through the newspaper he
got people to donate funds
which he then sent back to
the Cristero troops in Mexico.
But he too and his family
stayed in Chicago after the war,
made a living there,
raised children there.
One of his sons became a Catholic
priest who eventually went back
to Mexico when that
was legal once again.
And so these are migrants.
I know of many cases
of them but don't have
as many stories like this.
But there were thousands of
people like this who left
because of the war
for political reasons,
but also for economic reasons.
They couldn't maintain
their businesses
in Mexico during this conflict.
And so when they relocated
to the United States,
became business people in the United
States and made a living there.
So how do we classify
these types of migrants?
Typically, Mexican migrants
from this period are thought
of as labor migrants,
as economic migrants.
And we as historians have
talked about them in terms
of their economic motivations, their
economic interests and their labor.
And what I argue in my book, I call
this group the Cristero diaspora.
A scattered group of people
that supported the Cristero
cause from the United States.
And what I argue in my book is
that this story tells us something
important about Mexican migrants.
It tells us that Mexican
migrants were political actors.
That they rallied around
causes within their homeland.
That they had religious motivations.
And by the way, not all of Mexican
migrants supported the Cristero War.
Lots of them actually supported
the Mexican government.
And these people fought with
each other in the United States.
So Mexican migrants, you know,
need to be viewed outside
of this limiting lens of
economic or labor migration,
is my argument both
in the book and here.
And I think it helps us think
about something that we'll talk
about a little bit more
today, which is, you know,
how do these categories that we
try to stuff migrants into --
you know, are you an
economic migrant?
Are you a refugee?
Are you a political exile?
How can we blur these categories
in creative ways to think
about migrants differently?
So I'll stop there.
>> Ivan Chaar-Lopez: Thank you.
So thank you all for coming.
It's exciting to talk about my
project in large part because I'm
in the process of research
and writing it.
So I'm at a different
stage than my peers.
And right now my dissertation
project is titled Drone Techno
Politics: A History
of the Datafication of
the US-Mexico Border.
And it traces the long and
complicated trajectories
of databases and computers
as instruments
of empires since the 1960's.
Databases and computers I think
help us understand how drones later
on in the 2000's become
the technological choice
for border surveillance operations.
Now contemporary debates, as
Jason mentioned, demonstrate --
contemporary debates about the
border demonstrate a pressing need
to take a critical look into what
people call technological fixes,
or so-called technological fixes.
Doing so sheds light on how the
border operates as a laboratory
for modes of governing and
administering populations.
More precisely, the border I think
and I argue throughout
my project is a zone
where noncitizens become
expendable subjects
in the experimentation
of biopolitics.
My goal in the end
is to contextualize
and interrogate the
techno political fixation
on data, both big and small.
As well as on digital technologies
as end-all, solve-all solutions
to border policing and
immigration enforcement.
To do this I don't only
inquire how computers,
databases and drones are imagined.
I also open the technological
black box if you will,
to examine its internal operations.
So what do technologies
do, how do they do it?
What are their methods
for acting upon the world?
The way that I'm going about my
project right now is writing what I
call historical snapshots of
specific technological fixes,
or that question specific
technological fixes.
So the study begins with
a database system known
as the Alien Documentation
Identification
and Telecommunication System.
It's a mouthful so I say it slowly.
But ADITS, as it was known, created
in the 1970's, was at the center
of INS, or immigration
naturalization service.
The center of INS is the
process of automation.
It was really a very
important project.
And I look into this system
from 1975 and then I finish
with the Arizona Border Control
Initiative of 2004-2005 which is --
what I found so far is the first use
of drones in the US-Mexico border.
Now each snapshot follows a variety
of actors in federal government,
private industry, academic research.
It also looks into
journalism and activism to try
to trace the different types of
state work that computers, databases
and drones are imagined to perform.
And just to give you a little
sense of what I'm talking about,
which might sound a little bit
abstract, I have a few images
that I would like to share.
So this is just an aerial
take of the Santa Fe bridge.
This is the port of entry in
El Paso, in El Paso and Juarez.
And the added system would
be used in a port of entry.
So it's an identification system.
It's just a regular ID, alien card.
And it has a magnetic stripe and
different biometric data on it.
And it would be used
in the port of entry.
So I'm looking into
that kind of technology.
But then there's this
whole realm of the border
that is very remote
and hard to access.
And for that kind of terrain
the INS developed other
different technologies.
Or incorporated actually
military technologies.
And to give you -- so actually I'm
not going to pay attention to that.
So this is an example of it.
So this is a system
of connecting sensors,
electronic sensors, seismic sensors.
And it connects the sensors
to computers at headquarters
that sends information down
to patrol agents to try
to catch what they call
intruders from entering the US.
And this system, as I explain,
is developed to try to patrol
and control this remote area,
this remote borderlands.
And this is just a take,
a picture of the kind
of control headquarters
or control center.
It's showing the integration
of different screens.
Among them computer screens.
And it's kind of the first
moment where these kind
of technologies are
used on the border.
And I move from that to the drone,
which a lot of people
are familiar with.
But for the most part people
are familiar with drones
as a military technology
used for drone strikes.
Or what I think the Intercept papers
call the assassination complex.
But rather than paying attention to
that kind of development I'm looking
into drones within the US.
Military drones, not the quad
copters that are also very popular.
But the military drones
use on the borderlands.
And as you can see from this
diagram, it's very, very,
very similar to the previous diagram
I showed in the sense that the ways
that these technologies are being
imagined is very, very close.
So I'm trying to understand how did
that happen and what's behind kind
of the thinking of these different
government officials and researchers
when they come up with the
project or with their systems.
And yeah, we'll leave it at that.
>> Katherine Luongo:
Okay, thank you.
Thank you, Jason.
Thank you to the Kluge
Center and to our audience.
Like Ivan, I am in the midst
of writing up my research
and doing some research
as I continue to write up.
So today I'm going to open by
offering a couple of brief synopses
of cases that I have collected.
And then I'll talk a little
bit about the larger categories
that I think these cases
are representative of.
So in 2006 a man from Nigeria sought
asylum in Canada on the grounds
that the Nigerian state
did not offer protection
to the particular social
group that he belonged to:
persons accused of witchcraft.
The immigration and refugee board
of Canada rejected his claim
on the grounds that the documentary
evidence in this situation --
country conditions report -- showed
that "despite apathy and reluctance
on the part of the police, people
have been arrested by the police
and convicted before judges."
The claim was denied.
The asylum seeker appealed to
the federal court of Canada
for a judicial review of his case.
The judge noted that the board
had relied on documentary evidence
which dealt with people convicted
for practicing witchcraft.
I have noted the report "could
not constitute state protection
of persons wrongly
accused of witchcraft."
The asylum seeker was granted
a new hearing in this case.
In 2012, Namibian asylum
seekers, a mother
and her minor son, came to Canada.
They made the argument
that they belonged
to a particular social group at
risk for harm from witchcraft.
The mother explained that her
son faced a high risk of death
from witch doctors in Namibia.
The death of her parents had
been linked to witchcraft.
Competing for her inheritance,
her relatives had cursed her
and said she would
die like her parents.
Her brothers had respectively found
a big snake on their front porch
and another one found
a bowl of blood
with an owl on his front porch.
They took this as evidence of black
magic being practiced against them.
The asylum seeker said that
he'd never sought out protection
from state authorities
because her family was going
through witchcraft problems.
And as she explained "the state
cannot protect us from witchcraft."
The immigration and refugee
board rejected her claim,
saying that the harm that she feared
over her inheritance was
definitely a family matter.
It rejected the claim that her son,
who suffered from a condition that's
actually redacted in the decision,
did not face from witch doctors.
People suffering from his condition
were not killed in Namibia.
And they also rejected her claim
that the state offered no protection
from witchcraft and
cited a range of evidence
that Namibia was a democratic state.
So these cases are
exemplars of the archive
of nearly 40 cases
that I put together.
And what I'm examining is cases
in which African asylum seekers
who are coming from Anglophone
Africa to commonwealth countries.
To Canada, the UK and Australia.
Alleged that being accused
of witchcraft or targeted
with witchcraft makes them a member
of a particular social group subject
to persecution and eligible
for refugee protection.
So I think that these
cases offer avenues
to explore some key categories
in refugee status determination.
But also in the legal history
of witchcraft and the management
of witchcraft related crime
on the African continent.
So when I am talking about
witchcraft in these cases,
I'm talking about an embodied
capacity, an object or a practice
that mobilizes an invisible,
malevolent power to harm the person,
property, psyche or kin of another.
Asylum seekers have to show that the
state doesn't offer protection form
the kind of violence that they
allege that they have suffered
or that they will suffer if they
return to their country of origin.
So part of my project is to
inquire into the deep jurisprudence
about witchcraft on
the African continent,
and to establish a history to
these claims of the absence
of state protection from
witchcraft-driven violence.
Asylum seekers also have to show
that they meet one of the criteria
for refugee status that's laid
out in the 1951 UN
convention on refugees.
So these criteria are race,
religion, political opinion,
nationality and of course membership
of a particular social group.
And this convention
is really the lynchpin
of the refugee status
determination process.
So my project is taking
witchcraft-based asylum cases
as an avenue through which
to explore the expansion
of the social group criteria.
And this is the only
criterion of the UN convention
that has been expanding
in recent years
as asylum authorities have been
more inclined to hear arguments
that a social group
can be constituted
around cultural practices,
beliefs and perceptions.
This project also offers an avenue
to investigate how
expertise is constituted
and mobilized in legal settings.
In the colonial cases
that I am examining,
a category of intermediary,
native assessor,
typically men who were taken from
the local community that the parties
to the case belong to, operated as
interpreters of culture and language
between the parties to the
case and British justices.
They explained the
finer points of culture
that were brought up in cases.
They explained particular
vernacular terms.
And they bona fide or denied the
participants in the case's claims
about how culture operated
in their cases.
So something that I
found very striking is
that in asylum cases
today, social scientists,
very often anthropologists,
serve in the role
of a modern day native assessor.
As expert witnesses, they
serve as intermediaries
between the asylum claimants
and the asylum adjudicators
who are hearing the cases.
And they occupy many of the
same kinds of roles of cultural
and linguistic translation.
So some of the core questions that
I'm applying in doing this research
and in writing it up
is in the question of,
can the law effectively
intervene in witchcraft?
How is reasonableness constituted in
state courts and in asylum venues?
And what are the limits of cultural
relativism in asylum settings?
So I think that these cases
open up a lens through which
to consider the really global
reach of local forms of violence.
Thank you.
>> Jason Steinhauer: Okay.
Great, thank you all.
I'm going to take a little bit of
time to generate some conversation
between the three scholars
before we open
up to everybody else
in the audience.
And I want to touch on what all
three of you have alluded to
and mentioned, which is this idea of
labels, definitions and categories.
And that's something that we all
talked about amongst ourselves
when we initially thought
up the idea for this event.
And I believe it was Kate who
actually used this phrase,
which I loved, which was the
bureaucratization of experiences
into state-defined categories.
Which is kind of a mouthful.
But thinking about we
have people who are moving
for all various reasons in
history from places to places.
Sometimes we call them migrants.
Sometimes we call them immigrants.
Sometimes we call them refugees.
Sometimes we call them
asylum seekers.
And at each point, some body, some
state body, some governing body,
some global body has to make a
definition and a designation.
And each of you have come up
against this in your research.
So maybe we could star
there and talk a little bit
about these terminologies and
how they factor into the stories
that you're uncovering and the
research that you're doing.
>> Julia Young: Yeah.
Well, your comment
just made me think
about an interesting development in
the historical study of immigration
which people may or may not
know about, which is, you know,
in US immigration history --
so the history of immigration
to the United States.
One of the seminal, earliest
studies of migration is a book
by Oscar Handlin called
The Uprooted.
And it presents this image of
migrants as people who are the poor,
the downtrodden, people who are
uprooted from their local context
and then flung into their new land
and forced to recollect themselves
and reconstruct their lives.
Essentially it treats immigrants
almost as handicapped people,
people that are almost
a blank slate or people
who are without a background.
And the historiography on
immigration is changing
and has changed over
the 20th century
and it's increasingly recognizing
immigrants as people who come
with a political context, who come
with a background of their own.
And that they bring with them,
that they don't leave
in their home country.
They're not uprooted people.
They might be transplanted people,
or there are other metaphors
that people have come up with.
And I think that's a
positive development,
but I'm not sure it's translated
into public discourse
on immigration.
And I'm not sure it's translated
into the immigration courts, right?
These are people with
a real understanding
of the context which
immigrants left.
So I'll stop there.
>> Katherine Luongo: Yeah, I think
this issue of context is really key
in refugee status determination.
Because we have this popular
image of the refugee as someone
who has experienced some form of
trauma that makes it impossible
for them to stay in their home.
And therefore they leave and
they seek sanctuary elsewhere.
Hopefully they're welcomed
by the receiving state.
But there are very precise
legal definitions and categories
that a person has to show that
they conform to, to be eligible
for the rights and
protection of formal
or conventional refugee status.
And part of achieving that status is
as the asylum seeker
narrating your own experience.
But the legal systems are not
prepared to hear the deep context
that really illustrates
the different categories
to which refugee experiences belong.
And it's also complicated by,
as Julia has just suggested,
that very often there are
cross-cutting categories
that refugees belong to as well.
>> Jason Steinhauer:
In your research did your notice a
shifting language as you looked back
from the '50's, '60's,
'70's to today
in who the technology
is being implemented
to keep out or to monitor?
Is it immigrants, is it migrants?
Is it refugees?
Is it all of the above?
>> Ivan Chaar-Lopez: Well one of
the concepts or terms that comes
across a lot in the literature
is the idea of intruder.
And I'm not necessarily
sure of its genealogy,
but for sure there
is some relationship
to the Vietnam War as it's ongoing.
Particularly because of the
sensors that they're using.
They're bringing sensors
from Vietnam and this kind
of line simulation system
that I showed the diagram.
That is a kind of deployment of
a lot of Vietnam technologies
in the context of the
US-Mexico border.
So a lot of these different --
a lot of categories such as intruder
becomes kind of repositioned
because of the context to
signal particular subjects
especially migrants.
But there's also border
smugglers that are included
in the category of intruder.
Because you have to think that the
1970's -- the end of the '60's,
the beginning of the '70's
also marks the beginning
of the war on drugs.
And there's a lot of these different
technologies are employed as well,
not just to capture or to try to
target immigrants, but also to track
and capture border
smugglers of different kinds
of things, as well as humans.
>> Jason Steinhauer: I'm also struck
about how there are some
things that we can't keep out.
We go through all these
machinations to keep people out,
but there are things
that transcend borders
and that cross borders no
matter how hard we try.
There's religions and ideologies.
And as you were talking
about, there's politics
and political leanings
that we can't keep out.
Can we talk a little bit about
some of the things that are porous,
that spread across borders even
as there are these categories
that are meant to keep various
elements out of various places?
You've already mentioned
some of them.
>> Julia Young: Yeah, I mean I
would just say political conflicts.
You know, I've seen this in my
own work but also in other groups.
Someday I would like to write a book
comparing different migrant groups
who sort of brought their
homeland conflict with them.
I think it's more the rule rather
than the exception actually.
You can look at Armenians
or multiple other national
or ethnic groups who in some ways
not only bring their conflicts
with them -- or their
political causes with them.
But their political causes
become even more important
in the United States.
The Irish are an example of that.
Where that political cause or
conflict becomes a part of identity.
So that's something
that's very portable.
Somebody was talking about
portable nationalism.
We were talking about that.
We were talking about that in
the halls of the Kluge Center.
>> Katherine Luongo:
Yeah, I think I can answer
that question abstractly
and concretely.
So more abstractly,
I think we can talk
about narratives being
born across borders.
So as I think I suggested earlier,
the refugee's testimony really
about his or her own
experience really forms the core
of an asylum case.
And a lot of the literature
on refugee status determination
has talked about the culture
of disbelief with which many
asylum adjudicators approach
these narratives.
And one of the reasons is that
there are narrative brokers.
So you can go in your
home country to someone
who will tell you a story
that's been shown to work
in the asylum setting
where you're heading.
And you can adapt it a
little to make it kind
of your own legend almost.
More concretely, beliefs and
practices are born across borders.
So there have been cases in the
UK of witchcraft-based killings.
And I've also seen some
cases of human trafficking
where Nigerian women have been
taken to Europe and held enthralled
by their captors who have told them
that they have essentially
witch doctors on call at home
to curse the trafficked
women's families if they try
to escape from their traffickers.
>> Jason Steinhauer: Interesting.
Ivan, there was an article
in the New Yorker recently
chronicling a Syrian refugee
and how he made it first to
Cypress and back and then to Turkey
and Greece and eventually
all the way up to Sweden.
And as I was reading that
article I was thinking of you
because it talked about all of the
various ways that he used technology
to subvert border protection.
And I was thinking about your
research and all the investments
in technology that we have made
to enforce border protection.
Is that something that you
think about in your research,
how people have also subverted these
technologies using perhaps less
sophisticated or more
nave modes of technology?
>> Ivan Chaar-Lopez:
So the ADITS system,
as I mentioned, produced a card.
The goal was every alien resident
in the United States would
have this card as a mode
of identifying his or herself.
And that came about because the
original green card as it was called
that was actually used
since the 1940's,
there were different versions of it.
So there was no standard
version of a green card.
So they wanted to create
finally a standard version of it,
because a lot of migrants
crossing the border --
not through the checkpoints,
but even also through the
checkpoints themselves.
They carried what the
government thought were falsified
or fraudulent identifications.
So they were trying to kind
of police that practice.
And so the short answer is
these different technologies
that are created to remediate
maybe a transgression by a migrant
or by a group of people
are not perfect.
And even the same computer
engineers --
for example there's
an electrical engineer
that was working on the sensors.
He talks of how these systems,
not only are they not perfect,
but that they're also producing new
problems that need to be addressed,
need to be kind of
thought about constantly.
And that's just from
the researcher side.
And then the implementation
also leads to you know,
people creating false
documents, et cetera.
>> Jason Steinhauer: I'll throw
one more food for thought question
out there and then we'll
hear from everybody here.
When we originally spoke
we talked about how earlier
in human history there were
migrations happening all the time.
I mean, if we go way, way back,
people crossing the Bering
Strait or from Africa.
But even in more recent human
history, migrations across space,
across geographies,
across boundaries
that went largely unchecked
or unfettered.
But it seems to be sort
of correlated to the rise
of the nation state and the
modern day boundaries and borders
that we've drawn that we see the
migration of people from point A
to point B as a problem
that needs to be solved.
Or that needs to be somehow
mitigated in some way.
I was wondering if, as you think
about your own research and the work
that you're doing, how this idea of
the border and people crossing it
as a problem that needs to be
solved or an issue that needs
to be confronted -- how
you have seen that evolve.
How that has been talked
about by the various actors
and agents in your research.
Or if there's any other insights
on that very general theme
that you want to share.
Kate, you want to go first?
>> Katherine Luongo:
Yeah, that's fine.
So I think that the apparatus
around controlling the flow
of people has gotten more
and more complex over time.
So the cases that I'm looking
at have occurred primarily
in the last 20 years.
And I've been reading them in
conversation with the refugee law
in the places in which the
asylum is being sought.
And it seems to me those
bureaucratic institutions
and their mechanisms are
becoming ever more complex.
At the same time there's a real
push and pull that's quite apparent
between a kind of humanitarian
impulse
and then a desire for
resource control.
Which is really I think at the
root of this problem of migration.
>> Ivan Chaar-Lopez: Let me see.
So in the case of computers
and databases,
I would also say the same
thing in the sense that a lot
of the systems have grown more
complicated and more nuanced.
A lot of these computers early
on could only just perform
one particular task.
And you know, a lot
of the research was
that the computer could perform
the task as quickly as possible.
It was all about speed and
make it as fast as possible.
But today computers have
multiple functions and do plenty
of things simultaneously.
And what I'm studying or trying
to figure out is how algorithms,
the development of
certain algorithms,
complicate the practice
of sovereignty.
And I don't have an answer to that.
That's really like the big
question behind my project.
But just to give you a taste of
it, not really from my project
but from another experience.
So the NSA uses kind of
a citizenship algorithm.
This comes from the research of one
of my advisors, John Cheney-Lippold
So the NSA uses this citizenship
algorithm that determines
if the person that is being
surveilled is a citizen or not.
And if you are identified
by this algorithm
that you are 51% considered
noncitizen,
then you could be surveilled.
So citizenship becomes a gradation.
It's not a yes or a no thing.
Although it is a yes or now thing,
but it's quantified in such a way
that makes it almost possible
for anybody to be noncitizen.
So yeah, trying to figure out that.
>> Julia Young: So my research
is really focused on the 1920's
and 1930's, but of course I
voraciously read all news having
to do with migration now.
And so I think a lot
about what has changed.
And you know, one thing that
hasn't changed is there were lots
of Donald Trumps in the 1920's.
Really so many saying
such similar things.
And that's both depressing and
also sort of like reassuring
because all things will pass.
That's my hope anyway.
But in terms of you know, the
actual control of the border,
the 1920's is a really
interesting period
because it's really the first decade
that the US tries to get control
of the border between
the US and Mexico.
And it's not only to get control
over the Mexican migrant
population --
and we hear about this from
Ruth Watson a couple weeks ago.
Mexicans were not included
in the quota system
that restricted migrants during
the 1920's, this new quota system.
Neither Mexicans nor other migrants
from the western hemisphere.
And so they were technically
fee to cross the border.
But the Chinese and other Asian
groups were excluded completely.
And so the rise of the
border patrol and the efforts
to control the southern
border were initially meant
to control that population.
But very soon after, that control
began to be applied to Mexicans
and Mexicans began to be
seen as an invader group.
I don't know if I would use
the word invader for them.
But you know, as an
illegal alien group.
And May Nie has written sort
of the book on the policing
of the border and how that goes.
But it wasn't very
effective in the 1920's.
I mean the border is huge
and for the first few years
of the border patrol there
were 20 or 30 officers I think
and they're patrolling this
3,000-kilometer border.
There was no chance.
And you could pretty easily -- you
were subject to certain restrictions
when you crossed, but you
could pretty easily bypass them
and just walk across.
And it really remained that
way for most of the century.
That's different now and you're
telling us how different that is.
That's become very different
since the '60's and that's
because of this new technology.
And I would say the
major difference is
in how many people are dying
trying to get across the border.
And how much the border
has now become a site
of real human rights
tragedies in the way
that it really wasn't in the 1920's.
And I know there's one human
rights group that's trying
to get cell phone towers
installed along the borders
so that migrants themselves can make
use of wireless technology the way
that they're doing in
Europe to find themselves
when they're lost in the desert.
And there's resistance to doing that
from Donald Trumpians and their ilk.
>> Jason Steinhauer: Well I think
I've asked enough questions.
So I think it would be great
to hear from the audience.
Travis has a microphone.
The trick to that microphone is
I have to turn off my microphone
for it to work, which ensures that
I won't ask any more questions.
>> Than you all very much for that.
That was fabulous.
So I wondered if any of you had a
kind word for national sovereignty.
It seems to me that in national
sovereignty is somewhat defined
by the ability to control
one's borders.
And there's a traditional
value and expectation of that.
Usually we're not thinking of
migrants when we're saying that.
But a number of Jason's
questions went to legitimacy
of the exercise of sovereignty.
The reason for categories, the
reason for asylum and you know,
not an economic migrant,
but an asylum seeker.
People attribute certain
values as legitimate
to exercise of sovereignty.
And then they find another value
which will trump sovereignty.
No pun intended here.
Relax. What I'm wondering is --
I've talked to others in this field
and they actually answer my
question "Do you have a kind word
for national sovereignty?"
with "No, we don't."
That borders are destructive
of movement that's essential
if you truly value human life
in many parts of the world due
to conflict and other things.
I wondered how each of
you looked at sovereignty
and its legitimate exercise.
>> Julia Young: I can start.
I mean, I regard migration as
a fundamentally positive thing.
And I think that the way to
address if there are concerns
about a particular population that's
coming, it's not very effective
to address them at the border.
We talked earlier about
how migrants manage
to find ways around restrictions.
Maybe one day we'll get to a point
where states can actually
enforce true control over borders.
But up until this point,
migrant ingenuity has trumped --
again that word -- state
enforcement of the border.
But yeah, I mean I've asked myself
this question and I think I'm
in favor of open borders.
But I'd be up for a debate on that.
>> Katherine Luongo: Yeah, I think
it's a really complicated question.
And I'll go back to what I said
before about the push and pull
between the humanitarian impulse
and then resource allocation.
And I think that with the
specter of Donald Trump,
one of the questions underpinning
sovereignty is what the citizens
of the sovereign state believe
immigration is doing or not doing.
And I don't think that there
are very accurate understandings
of how immigrant populations
come to be in a particular nation
and the kinds of things that
they do once they arrive there.
>> I don't have a question
for each person.
I don't have a comprehensive
question.
I just have a quick
question for each if I may.
So for Julia, historians saw your
migrants as economic migrants.
But how did they come in?
Did they come in as asylum seekers?
Were they mostly given asylum?
Do you have any idea?
>> Julia Young: Should
we answer one-by-one?
>> Jason Steinhauer:
Let her ask Ivan.
>> For Ivan, on technology, I'm
just wondering about changes
and new technology changes.
The people employed to do the
work, to use the technology.
And then finally for Kate,
a question about the legal.
Whether the asylum seekers who
seek asylum under the category
of witchcraft, whether they
have legal representation
for the most part and
what difference that makes
and how it helps you
understand something
about the social economic
background.
Thanks.
>> Julia Young: Thank you.
That's a really good question.
And the answer is that it was messy
because the legal frameworks were
just being developed at this time.
And like Kate said, the
refugee law didn't really exist
until after 1951.
So a lot of the Mexicans
that I talk about,
there are multiple ways to come in.
Some people came without documents.
Some people came -- you
could come in without a visa
if you said you were going to
stay for less than six months.
So some people came in that way.
But there was a small group of
people who did come in in a sort
of quasi-refugee status,
and that was the clergy.
The US Catholic church
was very aware
of this conflict, as
you would imagine.
And they actually had
an immigration bureau.
Because the US Catholic church is
another very interesting story,
but they were very invested
and interested in immigration
and immigration policy at
this time, as they still are.
And so they had an
immigration bureau in El Paso.
And the personnel there actually
helped these refugee priests
and nuns apply for visas
and get them visas.
But they weren't called refugees.
They didn't really use the
term refugees and asylum.
But they did get them visas on the
basis of their being persecuted.
And so they came in as sort of
like recognized legal migrants.
But for a lot of people the
categories are much more slippery.
>> Ivan Chaar-Lopez: So with regards
to how technology changes the people
employed to do the border work,
one of the things that
I'm trying to tease out --
and I'm actually in the midst
of writing this chapter --
is how borders are
produced through technology.
So how boundaries are demarcated
from the technology itself.
To give you a specific example, in
the 1940's a group of researchers
in different places in the
United States become invested
in what later becomes
known as cybernetics.
And cybernetic theory
blurred the boundary
between living organisms
and machines.
And in the blurring of that
boundary, when you have an office
of planning and evaluation and INS
implementing new automated systems
into INS work, what they're doing
is imagining all the different
components of the system
as a machine.
So humans in some way become
machines or little machines
within the machine itself.
And in that way I think that that
is changing how the officials are
imagined or are thought of
by different policy makers.
And yeah, that would be my initial
response, is in the way that humans
and machines are thought
of within government.
>> Katherine Luongo: Yeah, on the
question of legal representation,
it's quiet, inconsistent and ad hoc.
And asylum seekers
can acquire attorneys
through various mechanisms.
In some cases there are
NGO's that specialize
in matching asylum
seekers with attorneys.
Large law firms will often have some
of their pro bono work
dedicated to doing asylum cases.
And of course if you have an
attorney you're in much better shape
in crafting the narrative that
you're going to be presenting
to the asylum adjudicator.
But it also gives you much
wider access to expert witnesses
who can support some of the claims
that you're making in your case.
>> So actually my question
was how many
of those cases have
legal representation?
Is it common or not so common?
>> Katherine Luongo: It really
depends on -- it really depends.
So I haven't broken it down,
but there are variations really
on a state-by-state basis
in Canada for instance.
But I would just say it's
inconsistent and ad hoc
to answer quite generally.
>> Jason Steinhauer:
We're approaching 5:00
so we have time for one more.
You can take the last one.
>> Thank you.
Thank you for talking
about your work,
and Jason for being
such a wonderful host.
I have a question for everybody.
It's provoked by Ivan
and I have some thoughts
about it with respect to Ivan.
You developed borderlands as a
concept, and I wonder how it helps
or how it works in your papers
to conceptualize the site
of contestation as a borderland,
as opposed to a border.
And as I'm sure you know, sort
of in the borderlands literature,
borders aren't finite spaces
that you jump across, right?
But are fluid spaces
within which identity
and agency is produced
and contested.
And so if that's the case,
you know, Ivan it almost seems
at war with your topic, right?
Because the topic sort of seems
to sort of conceptualize this kind
of hard border with all of the
work happening on one side.
I wonder what you think about that.
And also whether the real
sort of agency and identity
that is being produced --
is it essentially living
within the machine?
You know your last answer
was just so provocative
and I wonder whether you want to
think through sort of the agency
of the machine being
produced in this borderland.
>> Ivan Chaar-Lopez: So
that's a great question.
Let me see how to tackle it.
So going back to the, for example,
the different electronic
sensors on the border.
These sensors do not successfully
identify every time there is a
migrant passing by.
But it's actually giving signals
for different kinds of beings.
Because it's not responding
to, I don't know, to human skin
and saying, "Oh, there
is a human touching me."
But it's actually just sending
an electric signal with a sound
to the home base saying, "Oh,
there's something going on here."
And they send people there.
And what happens?
They find an animal.
They find a dog.
They find another organism there.
So these machines are
constantly failing.
Even though they're
working effectively,
in their effective
operation they're failing
to successfully differentiate
between the human and nonhuman.
So that's why I think the
borderlands framework is
so productive to look at technology.
Because it is not so neatly as
I've probably been showed it to be.
It's actually not.
It's actually failing constantly.
I can think of for example drones.
Drones are not flying
all of the time
as they're supposed to be flying.
But they're flying I think
a little bit over 50%
of what they're supposed
to be flying,
of the time they're
supposed to be flying.
So they're way down and that's one
of the reasons why
the inspector general
for Homeland Security is criticizing
the drone program and saying,
"This costs too much and
it's not doing the work
that you guys say it is doing."
But there are a lot of
different players that want
to see the drone program continue.
And that's why, you know, my
approach which is an actor approach,
looking into different actors.
You have to not only look at the
state but also look at the engineers
and look at the companies
behind these technologies
that are also really invested.
Quite literally they're invested
in these machines being
bought and being deployed.
And that's why I think the
comment of the electrical engineer
from the 1970's, I thought
his comment was brilliant
in this article I read.
And he's saying, you know,
these machines are
generating new problems for us.
And I included it because
I wanted to kind
of highlight how they're not
perfect and they're failing.
Yeah, sorry I went everywhere.
>> Jason Steinhauer:
Any last questions?
Okay. Well I think we ought
to leave it there then.
Please join me in thanking
all three of our scholars.
[ Applause ]
Just a quick bit of administrative
business before concluding.
We are conducting an
institution-wide survey
about our events.
That survey is on the
table right when you exit.
And we'd love to get your feedback
on this event and any other events
that you've been to
at the Kluge Center.
We hope to do more types
of these conversations
when scholars are working on topics
that intersect with each other.
So please do sign our email list.
And we at the Kluge Center are
on break for a couple weeks,
but we are back December 10th with
Mary Dubjack, our current chair
in American law and governments.
She will be sharing a
lecture about her research
on America's entry into World War I.
So please do join us for
that and thank you again
for being here this afternoon.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.